Welcome to the British Council
Learning Hub
When it comes to teaching English
to young children
our priority is to turn their
curiosity
into confidence
that's why we've introduced the
British Council Learning Hub
as part of their Primary Plus course
It's a safe and secure online space
where your child can continue their
English language learning adventure
at home
and it's a new way
New Caption
to suit your child's age
and personal development
so that they can complete
them independently
First you'll find all the information
you need
to activate your child's account
in your welcome email
We have another video to guide you
through the process if you need more help
Once logged on your child will choose
the module they're working on
and press open
welcome to Yummy!
a module from Primary Plus 1
it's all about food
First we want to show you
the features
that give parents a window into
the classroom
Such as your child's magazine
You'll find it in the resources section
This is what your child will use in class
with their teacher and classmates
There is one for every module
Let's see how you can track
your child's progress
You and your child will find the
progress dashboard
in the about this module section
Together you can celebrate your
child's successes
and encourage them with areas
for improvement
There are up to 10 activities
per module
that get more challenging as
your child progresses
te
Your child will find activities
in the first two sections
then songs and videos in sections
3 and 4
So let's show you some activities
Let's choose the Do you like
listening game
Here your child needs to match
what they hear
with the correct pictures
first they need to click on the
speakerphone icon
to listen to the narrator say
whether or not they like a certain
food
Do you like milk?
Yes I do
Your child then needs to decide
which of the four pictures
best matches what they've heard
New Caption
Once your child has finished
They can close the tab by clicking
on the X in the top right hand corner
Now let's try the Colour grouping
game
designed to help your child improve
their listening and reading skills
Here your child needs to group
words associated with certain
mealtimes
By clicking on the speakerphone
icon
your child will listen to the narrator
say
during which mealtime
they eat certain foods
For breakfast I like cereal
Your child needs to click
the paintbrush
in the pink paint
then select the foods the narrator
says they eat for breakfast
they can click on the green paint
to switch colours
then paint the foods the narrator eats
for lunch
finally they press finish
Songs make listening practice
fun for your child
This song is from the weather
module
First your child needs to read
the sentences
That are listed in the wrong
order
You can hear the song by clicking
on the play button
They need to listen out for
the sentences
So that they can list them in the
right order
They can also click on and read
the transcript
below the video
To complete the activity
they need to click once on the
sentence they want to move
Then once on the sentence they
want to replace
They can click finish to see if they
have made the correct choices
If not they can try again
Like in classes
Our partnership with academy
award winning
animation studio Aardman
helps us bring English
learning to life
to keep your child engaged
When your child completes
their activities
they can watch a Shaun the Sheep
video as a reward for their efforts
When your child moves up to
Primary Plus 3
they will enjoy learning with
even more stimulating activities
that they can do before and after
class
This new approach will help
them feel
more prepared
free up more time in class
for speaking
build up their confidence
and enable them to make
more progress
in the English language
learning journey
There really is a lot to look
forward to
Bye